so what kind of mean are you looking for
um how long is your daughter here she's
nine once so where's her father what's
going on with you guys um he's in the
hospital so yeah he's been he's very ill
so I'm looking for like a stepfather
wait
so you broke up with a lies in the
hospital no no I didn't break up with
him we are not together when he went to
the hospital
whoa baby we're still together wait okay
I'm looking for like you know just in
case
a stepfather just in case that's the
case if he passes away right are you
serious yes Kendra you have to have one
in the chamber Kendra come on you you
gotta click click click click you gotta
have one in the chamber you didn't found
out fine you got to have one ready to go
gotta have one too pop I always
appreciate it when you see someone doing
something crazy and you're like are you
doing something crazy and they're like
wait you don't do this and they trying
to make you feel crazy oh she didn't go
you don't do this
she went come on you have to do this
right it's a different level you don't
do this I'm questioning myself like you
know come on now even though everybody
do this that's even worse
bring it to another level that's crazy
is it this this is crazy I mean if she
her man no she's not doing anything
beyond him back
it's crazy on so many levels you're
broadcasting this live on Instagram is
your reputation and then his reputation
which is a terrible look for both of you
you just nuked yourself what do you mean
how are your friends and a family gonna
look at you that's a bad look forever
City to be how do you not I can't I
can't go to the hospital because it's
like you know all hospitals are shut
down okay but shouldn't you be waiting
to see like is there not looking good
it's not looking good are you a comedian
yeah kick No
Candida I'm not a comedian oh you're
serious I'm serious we have a type of
relationship that's like we're very
realistic my husband is much older than
me as well how old is your husband um
she knows she knows she knows how this
is gonna make her look this is not
acting you know there's some times where
you can just tell the videos fake this
is not fake
you know she's will aware the perception
that was her like a my goodness yes
because she's no she's gonna be judged
so for me I'm just watching this like
wow why would you get on it the people
clout sinks in men he's 65 he'll be 66
in a month or less a little bit less
than a month how old are you 32 well I
hope your husband survives and I hope to
not good then I hope he divorces your
ass because I'll be surprised and then
leaves you because any wife of his
that's the guy you're a really good wife
as you're looking for a person why he's
still in the hospital bed this is crazy
but grey do you okay all right bye baby
I when a black woman says bye baby
doesn't mean she likes you oh it's great
to me I'll be the voice with you leave
your ass right there and you ain't got
none and your name
bless your heart Terry Stotts I got no
pass but I got a thought listen all
right this is my thoughts if they don't
know I don't care about the business hmm
right
they're both content and I don't they
know how it is but you know it's just a
way that made me made me think of you
know some how some some men and women
when their significant other are in
prison they go around town they do
anything because they're you know I
gotta take care of the plumbing
and then they take care of the plumbing
the person is going for like your three
years nine other [ __ ] gonna be
in the house you know I miss make me
think of that this guy is going away for
life I mean that's what's going on
that's well that so I'm like yeah I see
it I don't really add that wouldn't be
my type of relationship is she
scandalous yes you know you got to keep
one in the chamber
he got what a scandalous woman so I feel
no sympathy for he knew what he was
getting in he paid for a transaction he
got the transaction and now that the
product shuffle is about to die she's
gonna pick up the next model it is what
it is you treated your relationship like
a transaction as much as people want to
get mad at her and say she's sick she's
sick you have to be pretty sick to want
to get with a girl like that that or
your eyes are just really pathetic
whatever whatever your things but any
other day you have to have that
accountability so for me
at the end there I look at this I'm like
it makes me cringe it sets a bad
precedent I don't like the idea and I
hope we never come to a point it's our
society where we embrace and encourage
gold-digging I hope we don't correct the
idea of using each other transactionally
all the time within our relationships to
me it's not a good look so it's never
gonna be something I'm gonna endorse or
encourage that being said how can we all
be mad at her when this man got with her
knowing this allegedly this is all her
silence jokes we don't know he's in the
hospital dying right now but if he you
have to be a pretty cold-hearted person
to know that your husband is dying in a
hospital right now you get on Instagram
live you don't even do it behind closed
doors exciting it is you know you have
to be pretty arrogant pretty arrogant to
get on Instagram live in front of
hundreds of thousands of people and be
like I'm looking for the next guy while
my husband's dying right now
that is pretty trash but if he mail he
knows I mean it does irrespective
irrespective of whether he knows or not
that's trash on her part hmm to be on
broadcasting it like you know what I'm
saying but he's enabling her for sure
allegedly alleged we have to ask you
plus one that has craig's it's just the
brazenness of the scandalous Ness you
know what I'm saying what the brazenness
of the scandalous miss if I say that ss
a couple more times I'll be like what oh
you know what it's like it's like when
you see real life and real life is far
more crazy than any novel you've read
yeah that's one of those stories there's
the Lord of the Rings and there's this
above it you know what I'm saying like
elves that's crap
but one in the chamber that's the best
series like a Harry Potter book Harry
Potter and the one in the chamber on the
other hand maybe this is just the best
husband ever and he's just like girl get
a head start do you think yeah cuz
you're not in my will so you better find
some next [ __ ] to take care of you yeah
maybe he's just the best this the best
husband of the year warm and maybe she's
the most responsible mother ever and
maybe she's not back handle it we don't
know maybe we're all misjudging her yeah
you're always bashing women yeah and
maybe we just all need one of the
chamber kick Harry Potter and the one in
the chamber but if I couldn't even hold
someone's hand in public to get on net
and do this that's crazy man
if God bless y'all do you think it's
cloud chasing know how things will see
some clouds here's what I suspect it is
and this is why only reason why alright
because this girl started mocking her
and looking down on her and she stayed
there and defended herself and like to
me seemed like it was more about cuz if
she was truly looking for a man I don't
think she would be trying to engage with
somebody who's mocking her and was
clearly judging her negative but she I
think she's used to the people people
just know who she's fair I'll bet you
stayed there for the cloud chase she's
just stayed there because you know some
people want some people they have
options to leave but they stay there and
defend themselves sometimes we do that
in the comments I don't have to reply to
you Holly
I don't have to reply but sometimes we
reply to people that have been
whatever-whatever
we stay there and we engage we could
leave we could leave that all there and
they're clowning and clowning but we
stayed there it's not because she has a
way out that it's actually is just she's
doing it for the cloud or anything at
some point when you're defending your
honor I should say yeah sometimes you
get stuck there it's kind of a hook like
no but this mother you have to let it go
you have to leave but you stay there
even though you could just leave it
there yeah once you engage sometimes
it's hard to leave and that's what
happened when she started looking down
at her like hold on you just know let me
clear my name out because I'm gonna
leave on you a bunch of unknown unknown
so she did the best that she could and
you know cancer was not having it so no
I don't think it's cloud cheese I don't
think it was any look like I'll give you
that one
alright cool well that's it for today's
video so what'd you guys think about
this and this incident what do you think
about the woman what do you think about
the man what do you think about what we
said about this whole topic we want to
hear your comments in the comments below
[Music]